foreign
in Atlanta Georgia what's up Zoe
hi how's it going
it's going good I'm super nervous I'm a
huge fan oh gosh don't be nervous thank
you for being a fan but don't be nervous
I'm I'm I promise I'm not very good at
this what's up
okay so basically in essence like I
guess a simple question is how do I deal
with having anxiety or postpartum
anxiety specifically
um with my husband who doesn't really
understand mental health or really like
believe in mental health issues I don't
know if that's the correct way to word
it
um but I guess I can give you background
information if that's helpful
yeah because my first thought is well
you should just leave them but that's
probably not that's probably not going
to be helpful
um so
yeah
sorry one second
sorry
he's from another country so they don't
really talk about mental health the way
we do here in America so that's and he
also has never had any mental health
struggles I guess but I've always kind
of dealt with anxiety so I have a little
bit more experience with that it's not
that he doesn't believe in it but he
kind of equates having anxiety to stress
so if I'm ever telling him like oh I'm
anxious he's like what are you anxious
about like just go fix it and do what
you need to do to not be anxious when
it's not really that simple so he
doesn't understand I guess it's more of
a complex issue where I can't just go do
the dishes and then no longer be anxious
you know
have you gone to see a counselor
I haven't okay that's we need to start
um a couple of things one
you can't continue to go to
a source for
somebody to hear you to connect with you
when they are telling you I don't know
how to connect with you I don't I don't
even yeah this connection is never going
to happen
and so I do think it can happen but you
have to decide to stop going to him for
that because he can't provide that for
you he doesn't have a he doesn't have a
cultural context for it
my hope would be someone who didn't have
a cultural context could have a
scientific context or have a
um professional context and so I want
you to go to a counselor
and get some support and care there and
at some point invite him to come with
you
okay do not do that at the beginning
because you're gonna have to
be you're gonna have to do the work you
need to do to heal the ecosystem that
has given you this anxiety and some of
it if it's from before you were pregnant
there it could be any number of things
um if it's postpartum then it could be
any number of things but you need to sit
down and get that stuff worked out and
begin not worked out in a
um you need to fix that that's not I'm
talking about yeah but you need to get
some tools and get some insights into
why your body is trying to protect you
in that way trying to take care of you
in that way and what alarm Bells it's
sounding
and then invite him in and hopefully a
professional
who's got an ability to teach and inform
can give him insights that he's not able
to hear from you okay that's that's
helpful quit going back to him for it
because he's not gonna he's not quit
going back to import he's not going to
give it to you okay and I just want to
say he is like incredibly supportive and
loving and all of that it's just he
doesn't understand so he doesn't know
how to like support me in that area and
the way that I need to be you know so I
think it is helpful probably for me to
go seek well and let me let me dig into
that for a second when you say he's not
able to support me what do you think you
need when it comes to support
um
I don't like sometimes
sometimes you know I'm so sorry that you
were struggling today and kind of give
me a hug and things like that like I was
talking to him about it last week and he
was like because he works from 10 a.m
until midnight five days a week so it's
I'm basically a single mom five days a
week and so
um that can just add a lot of stress
into my life and um so I was talking to
him about that last week and he was like
well maybe you need to go get a hobby
like play tennis or something and I was
like I mean I'm lucky if I can shower
for more than three minutes at this time
so I'm not really looking to go
play tennis you know yeah but um it
sounds like a guy that
I'm not trying to give him a pass but
he's not going to be able to help meet
your needs and support you in the ways
that you need unless you are very
explicit in how you teach him
yeah because how would you recommend I
just like this my wife and I have had to
come up with a whole different language
because like him when she said she was
struggling with something I just solved
it because I'm a genius and I know
everything yeah right and come to find
out my wife is 10x smarter than me she
didn't need my
my
advice she needed me just to sit with
her and listen and say that sucks
yeah and so she taught me that
by saying this hey I know you love me
and I know you want to connect with me
and when you told me just to go play
tennis that tells me you don't even have
a clue as to what I'm working through so
can I teach you in real time how to love
me better
if he says no to that then you'll have
bigger issues like most men he would say
oh God please anything any sort of data
would be helpful yeah because here's
what I bet happens I bet you reach out
and you say man today was this and the
kid diarrhea all over me and puked on me
and then we had a lunch date and then
they got canceled
and
he responds with how he would deal with
those situations
yes and then he feels you get
disappointed and mad at him
and he doesn't know why his wife doesn't
like him very much and you don't know
why you can't just sit with me and be
quiet it's all that
you see what I'm saying yeah that's
that's that's perfect and it's yeah
exactly what it is where he tries to
help and he really does try to help but
he doesn't
like like you said with your wife he's
more solution oriented so he's like well
what do we do and sometimes it's not
like there's nothing you can really do I
guess I just want support in that way so
and don't use don't use words like
support
use words like
um my wife will say this and we've been
married for almost 21 years she will say
I just need you to sit by me and hold my
hand while I tell you this
and that's a signal to me to be quiet
and then sometimes she will say I am
being vulnerable and I'm gonna ask for
your thoughts on this
and I'm not gonna lie when she says
those words I want your thoughts I get
so fired up and excited that I can
actually
feel like I'm helping
because I'm so insecure in my own
presence that I think the only way I can
help is by running my mouth which isn't
true
yeah but she taught me
she taught me
yeah the same as in the morning her is
Her Sacred private time like that's like
it's just
such an important time
and so for years I would wake up and I
am bouncing off the walls at 5am and
she is like a like a ghost coming out of
a Mist like kind of slowly the molecules
are finally coming together to form a
human and I'm like hey what's up uh and
so she had to teach me hey you're a lot
in the morning and I had to teach her
it really breaks my heart that you won't
at least say good morning
and she says good morning every morning
now and it's awesome we have a moment
and I'm quiet
I take my drama downstairs right you
know what I'm saying so all to say is we
honor each other by not asking each
other to read our minds
yes we don't say words like support or
um
or care for me or love me I gotta be
specific gotta be explicit here's what I
need and then
you got to be prepared for the
vulnerability because if you tell him
exactly what you need
and he goes nah I'm not doing that
then you have to deal with the fact that
you're married to a jerk
but most people just skip straight to
jerk and they don't ever give their
spouse or their boyfriend or girlfriend
or whoever they love the opportunity to
fully meet their needs because they
don't say them out loud
all right
my guess is if you will honor him
by
being very explicit about your needs
that he will meet those needs
and begin to connect deeper with you
and
your anxiety will slowly start to fade
yeah I really do
so right do you need anything from him
um I think you're right my problem was
like thinking of support as just this
General thing and not being specific
about what I need
so I think that would be really helpful
that's awesome and here's how it starts
the conversation if I'm you
I would start with
I've been using these big amorphous
words like support and care
and I've left you to to guess and try to
figure it out and that's not cool
and so I'd like to love you and honor
you by being specific
and so there's gonna be two ways you can
help me one I just need you to sit by me
and listen ugh
or sometimes I might ask you for your
insights
and I'm gonna ask you please don't don't
um give me advice or your wisdom if I
don't ask for it
but I promise I'll ask for it when I
need it
just give him that
give him that also I want y'all to try
SOS skin on skin contact four times a
day doesn't have to be sexual in fact it
usually isn't it can be if you want to
knock your lights out but it doesn't
have to be
just right when y'all wake up in the
morning
just 10 15 30 seconds holding hands
putting your foot on his foot under the
covers right before you leave he leaves
for work right when he gets home
um
and then right before bed and he works
till midnight so maybe that's not
possible but do it the best you can
get some skin on skin contact no talking
no solving no no
running through the ticker tapes just
being together
let that exhale happen
thank you so much for the call Zoe and
please um
if you continue to have postpartum
anxiety this anxiety is new after you've
had a baby
um please go see your OB GYN go see your
doctor and let him or her know hey that
you're still struggling with this
because it may be completely outside the
realm of just emotional health it may be
some true biological things going on